hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within
we're just starting to get into the meat
of this game and I figured out how to
remove the letterbox on PC they said
there might be some bugs to it but I
thought it might be a better experience
for everyone watching on YouTube because
the letterboxing can be awkward on the
small youtube screen but either way
we're getting back into it now I do have
some grievances with this games that I
mentioned in the last one oh yes Leslie
was being treated here years ago was
just ahead is the hospice my brother
runs he'll take us in that didn't answer
my question
yeah I honestly don't know for all I
know I'm losing my mind and you're just
a delusion but I'd like to think I still
have a shred of dignity and an
obligation to protect my patient oh oh
sure yeah because the worst concern that
I have is that everyone's being a big
meanie puss now there's a lot of
questions out of having this game don't
leave me behind you're way ahead of me
alright before we go into the hospice I
just want to get a bearing on where we
are we've got some scarecrows over there
I hear some music coming from somewhere
what is that am I supposed to go
directly into a my supposed to explore a
little bit because it seems like there
might be something here that I need a
lot of this a game like I was saying
about my grievances with it um they're
not exactly warranted on what I'm doing
you saw something move what don't tell
oh oh oh hi would you like a bottle of
wine to the face you're a big fella it
looks like you're gonna used to drink
okay okay stop moving oh I'm completely
out of ammo this was a terrible decision
did not expect there to be a dude here
don't grab me with your weird hands I
need to get in that room there's
something in there let me throw another
bottle in your face and then I'll smash
you to pieces
come here bro come here papa oh I missed
wildly Tebbit oh it's gonna take forever
to beat you to death
okay I'm gonna I'm just gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go and hope that I
can get in there and out of there before
you have a different idea of what you're
supposed to do with me okay so what are
we having here ooh a chest I smashed
that window for no reason okay hello oh
there was a bomb in there oh oh oh okay
bullets yes please Oh Matt fragment yes
I know the map in the map
okay I'm gonna use this on your face
what what you're not allowed to do that
okay I'm outta here
screw you buddy you're just an a-hole I
need another bottle of booze to smash
them with though I can get a good shot
at him there's a lot of stuff around
here than I need to find a map fragment
you know stuff that I haven't been able
to really collect cuz I've been busy
thank you
come on stop flailing oh come on no that
direct there we go thank you very much
yeah okay I'll get to Lesley now I'm
going for Lesley I just had to take care
of something I don't know the map
fragment does to put the map is in the
earth real world that is over yonder way
oh oh that's where the music was coming
from let me just take this ax real quick
never know when I might need one Journal
Sebastian Costin ellos February 2005
Miura was almost killed this morning
shot by suspect we're pursuing thank God
I was there she's gonna be okay because
of my heroics but seeing her bleeding
like that of thinking I was gonna lose
her without telling her how I really
feel was unbearable I think she feels
the same way there's something
undeniable between us it's against the
code of contact but I have to tell her
how I feel I hope I'm not setting myself
up for embarrassment okay so there's
some secret romantic pass to this
otherwise totally normal detective here
who doesn't have any issues
in his past and doesn't drink to sorrow
for Amanda whoa what the hell is going
on here hello lady lady okay got another
map fragment okay so I guess I'm
supposed to find all of them but I might
have already lost some because I haven't
seen everything hi lady I'll be with you
in a second I got another key I got to
open the door here oh excuse me
yeah I was just saying how this is more
combat oriented horror game and not that
there's anything wrong with that oh
hello
I need this yes please not that there's
anything wrong with that because this is
designed to be you know oh I don't have
any keys left it's designed by the same
guys that made Resident Evil which was
always a combat oriented horror game and
there's nothing wrong with that it's not
my experience of playing these games but
that doesn't mean that they can't be
creepy as we are seeing right now it
just means that there's gonna be peaks
and valleys in between action and horror
and that doesn't mean it's a bad thing
oh I can't save Oh God
where did that lady go nurse nurse who
is probably a piece of my past that I
need to very much forget I'll do that
later actually I don't think she went
that way
waiting's err is that the lady it wasn't
black and white before was it when I
have a trouble remembering lady don't
you pull a jump-scare out no not that
way so I'm not supposed to go that way
let me be clear why not okay
oh you have blood on your
[Music]
so many new admissions not a single
discharge I was right oh right this may
not be my mind but it's the hub for
everyone else
okay why is there crunching of bones
Leslie oh don't you dare you [ __ ] dude
take care of yourself okay thanks lady
are you that's all right then all right
then I'm just gonna go on my way don't
mind me
it's gone I think I have points enough
to upgrade something yeah I don't know
if I should upgrade my shotgun er if I
should upgrade my pistol only I mean the
pistol is good but the shotgun that's
love clears rooms all right oh yeah I
can okay you know what I gotta go for
the shotgun because the shotgun is like
the typical zombie thing and there are
zombies here clip capacity no way oh I
need to carry more bullets that's what I
need I need to be able to carry what's
sex that's nothing what's good as six
gonna do me I no one's gonna be able to
kill everything in a room but still fire
a reload I guess uh damage all right
damage Augustana and crit okay damage
and credit because when I'm
I want to make sure that everything dies
horrible and someone had point out that
the the reason I had the gun and the
bolts and I don't have the weapon yet is
because i pre-ordered it and I got the
pre-order bonuses which means that I
have stuff that not everyone's gonna
have I should have exited out the window
there but I decided to go here because I
wanted to check out see if Leslie
how you doing Leslie I can't even open
the door I can't even touch the door oh
that was legitimately creepy shooting
points hi Josh a little uncomfortably
close Jesus are you gonna be like a
Watson from that one Sherlock Holmes
let's see that video the really creepy
Watson and like even the developers
played on it it was really really well
done oh no my ex my ex is gone damn it
soon the gun the axe okay alright so
let's go into the hospice and finally
find out what's going in I guess weird
the pacing is so odd in this game it
like takes me forever to get to one
moment ooh I think I might be full up on
those yeah but I need one so I'm gonna
use those uh which slide I want to
accidentally okay so it's not even to a
slot because they ran out so I'll do
that I'm gonna put that on for just in
case I need the grenades later I mean
that's the bigger med kit I don't need
to use that right now they do need a
smaller one oh I wonder what could have
happened here
so much going right in this world excuse
me sir your victory
okay okay I did not mean to go into the
cutscene oh I don't mean to compare this
but I am trying to keep this as its own
game what are you doing bottle of booze
a bottle of booze okay I don't have any
shotguns but I got this whoa I may not
have enough ammo for this guy nice
headshot he went down a lot quicker Oh
everything shaking
[Music]
oh I'm sorry house till I make you mad
what you can't do that can't just
respawn oh oh what hi
what is happening in this game oh man I
was just talking dumb actor Valerio who
could have done what - Valerio your
brother Valerio wasn't too stable
impossible what are you talking about
doctor are you itchy whose ruvik subtly
mentioning someone that's important to
the story okay oh there are keys in his
stomach three keys good how do i excuse
me I excuse me I need it okay see you
okay I got it oh do I go do I get - oh I
get - don't I why would I do that
Oh God oh okay well there's no
hesitation going on here it's like in
Red Dead Redemption with you stirred
skinning animals no no no okay we should
have expect one key there were three
very clearly there were three in you can
I dive back in whoa wait a minute hang
on huh
let me just shine my light in here guy
other keys hiding around in your crevice
or anything huh
just this is gonna be a funny jokes let
me do it huh you got any keys in there
huh
you got a bright light shining from
within you you're a spark of imagination
if you weren't dead you'd be great okay
I'm out of here it's alright hey Doc how
you feel about me shooting your brother
in the face okay
let's carry on where are we going in
this crazy ass town there anything else
here I need green goop yes do not miss
that I need as many upgrades as possible
even though that wasn't very much scuse
me sir sir excuse me
stop being so disturbingly creepy oh we
could stop for a delicious meal matches
I mean I don't need to burn as many
bodies if I just blow up their heads
so long as I'm a good shot I should be
fine but this is me we're talking about
oh god this game is getting disturbingly
creepy I mean I don't mind the move
hi are you a thing your thing are doctor
stop talking in riddles
I need clear answers here things are not
going well you gonna tell all right more
brain juice that was a bit more so
that's good okay one more door and I
think we're done here
whoa hey whoa sorry come on it was right
there whoa there are no non-combatants
in this world yeah kids stuck on a
corner I had a look okay there we go
I almost had him sorry I just wasn't
quick on the draw there oh let me just
scoop up his blood it's perfectly normal
more brain juice more brain juice more
brain juice tonight was that oh that was
this curtain should I be worried about
those bloody thinks oh thank you sir oh
good shotgun shells I need those I love
my shotgun I wanna upgrade it to maximum
capability Jake open this oh no that one
gets gently opened I suppose I should
have gently opened the other one I swear
that's gonna move sometime I don't want
no weeping angels in here No thank you
no no I didn't even notice those on the
way in
yeah a doll like last night like does it
Oh
[Applause]
Wow I just crushed the light inside Oh
God
Oh bye lady I could have sworn I just
crushed that lady's head are you you're
gonna get a face full of this Oh weird
mask oh no no no no no weird Rosco
thought I had an axe first Wow okay this
is not going well I just need to shoot
you because I'm about us okay there we
go
thank you yes shotgun shells I love it
I'm taking way too much damage I'm being
too run-and-gun about this
what clothes thank you doctor what was
even the point of that I thought I was
standing a little close there doc all
right whatever you know what whatever
it's okay so uh anyway let's move on
whoa lady oh I saved you what the fudge
yeah I saved her I did good
oh boy heartburn bolts that I can't use
can I break those boxes down there no I
can't okay let's get excuse me doctor
what the hell is that thing that's some
ancient colonial loom used to spin Co
hello guys up there okay so I can sneak
up on that guy I should be able to kill
him
hello Peggy Peggy you enjoying your
straw just pigs don't eat straw wait was
that just a scarecrow is that actually a
thing oh so he's gone now huh that was
actually a thing you can't fool me I
know other thing was that go the wrong
way what's in there where am I going
excuse please what is all this I'm so
confused like everything kinda is dark
and looks kind of the same so oh okay
they're all right I suppose I'm supposed
to go towards the glowing door but I
don't think I've been in here whoa
what's that was the point of that all
right then
whatever nevermind it's gonna carry on
it's really hot in this room right now
I'm sweating up a storm okay so there
was something in here worth getting was
that just a warning to stay away when
some ghost runs out on fire oh oh no you
did oh no you don't okay hello who's
ruvik what why is ruvik whoa okay
villagers know they got Norman this
cries for help just cut off
I can hear screaming every night if I
don't stay hidden I know I'll be next so
why did you make noise scribbling a note
just going on here I have no idea what's
going on okay hang on I need to grab
another one of these things
alrighty then nothing Bad's gonna happen
hey doc dad let me do all the dangerous
work you just have fun over there let's
go find Leslie who probably screamed for
help like five minutes ago I ignored it
oh hey where's that come from oh that
came from the Burnie Ghost
really
what's wrong with this kid Oh Leslie was
here the whole time
I really did get startled by those uh
those scarecrows there oh I'm sweating
I'm actually nervous this is the first
time in this game where it started to
get really creepy I appreciate that I
don't know what's gonna throw at me next
yes bullets please I need lots of
bullets unless they're arming me up for
something like a boss battle I don't
know why I need this many bullets but
I'm not gonna complain am i full up on
reloading he's gone down there yeah oh
go down into the basement exactly where
I want to go I gotta admit that seeing
it in full screen is actually a lot
better than what I was doing before
like the cinematic view has his purposes
but a lot of people were talking like
that was like a forced limitation is the
hell lighting necessary it was a forced
perspective to limit what was going on
who harpoon gun cause bone oh that's not
what I needed
oh I mean it's fine I'll take it but
who's just one bullet laughs fine
whatever
I'm hoping to get a harp and harp and
gun or a crossbow or something to shoot
these bolts they seem fun on a bun okay
yeah the hell lighting very comforting
fooling around I'm kicking doors open
what are you doing old man not that I'm
exactly oh oh it's a photographer dude
thing guy oh this is another bottle wait
a minute
that's me that's me right there with my
signature outfit look like every
detective ever in the world that's a big
guy smiling that's all me all my faces
are like seven days to die they're all
worn out that guy's eyes are gone yeah
it's all kind of creepy closer I look at
that it's a little more creepier
I think something's coming what the hell
what is that Oh God anybody I can see
like a faint itty-bitty outline no no
yeah you burn you burn baby you burn you
burn up did I burn it and burn it okay I
guess I burned it good god oh don't tell
me those things are gonna be sneaking up
on me hmm
there we go burn it burn that son of a
[ __ ] okay yeah I kill there anywhere
safe at all I think that's unlikely
yeah good cuz things are about to get
weird I knew it just I knew it couldn't
just be zombies I knew there had to be
really creepy enemies out there we must
be going this way I mean of course is
gonna be cannon fodder zombies goddamn
that's a cool enemy that's a really cool
enemy okay
she's feeling that wall up the stairs
have gone
wait the stairs were to the levee
collectively losing our minds losing our
minds
oh that Rubick Rubick ate it hey you
totally called it I'm gonna show you
don't follow with don't following wait
don't follow him don't follow the guy
that I'm very clear oh I shouldn't have
followed him doctor OS Lee what the hell
[ __ ] oh my god the hell is going on who
skulls on the ground is that Leslie in
the doc okay wait a minute oh I guess
I'm supposed to go towards the door that
would be a smarter decision although
none of this is probably very smart
oh good blood on the walls I thought
this place could use some interior
decorating
the shining up in this [ __ ] elevator of
blood oh good
alright bye now yep that's blood I know
that taste what's going on it's
obviously a meat factory where all the
meat is woman we got home and meat
swimming in an ocean of blood fun times
for everyone
oh god who's getting gory oh okay
everything well good I'm waiting for
that am I supposed to go up here it's
all good
it's all just filled of bliss everything
is laughs okay okay okay wait can i
light that on fire
I can whoo that good crowd control I
guess where am I going
how about okay where am I going
hello more ladders oh gosh screw you
okay so am i able to disarm that one or
is it gonna blow up I'm gonna blow up
aren't I I'm so gonna blow up okay here
we go that's hard to do I should've just
snuck by here's a de facto thing I'm
just gonna sneak by from those from now
on cuz it ain't worth it oh god I'm out
of health I got the big med kit though
so let me wait let me use that one so
use that one up well that looks like a
switch to some sort of flammable oh oh
oh hey then nevermind I'm obviously
going the wrong oh god oh god there are
traps everywhere how is this okay Oh
what does this do Oh God
okay oh I can use that okay so that's
just an eternally spewing arrow machine
thing I am gonna try to keep the pace of
doing one chapter
Oh blood party
wait that's gonna get the call okay so
not the chainsaw guy but a bunch of
other friends who I can use the bomb on
you okay so we use the bomb on you hey
friends come to the party it's a fun
party
oh that didn't do [ __ ] oh god oh god oh
god we okay run run get up please
get the gun whoa oh right in between the
legs I don't know what this says what
I'm doing it well I didn't help buddy
buddy Oh
[Music]
fire fire fire burn you bastard where
you going okay so you're gonna go
goddamnit oh I'm such a bad shot walk
through the fire you do she's got a
shotgun with somebody's name on it but
except this isn't it how am I supposed
to kill all these guys I'm gonna run out
of bullets
yeah you all lined up like ducks in a
row someone's heads gonna get explode
not you whoa he's got a hole in his face
okay so I got it I didn't break this you
mean ammo god damn so it's in the
shotgun I got two bullets to two shells
actually okay well I thought that was
someone nearby me come on come on
down down no you don't care we go under
okay yeah okay I need to burn him cuz
he's not he's gotta get back up I killed
him I killed him dead I'm good at games
and whatnot
he gave me shotgun shells - I need those
badly I'm hoping that there's gonna be a
whole bunch of stuff to collect after I
killed all those guys yes another
grenade I don't know I think that my
first grenade killed a bunch of people
but I'm not sure so what was the point
of the body dropper here what was the oh
god oh oh that's horrifying
Oh Sol's death cap I don't I didn't want
to jump down there okay okay ah this was
what I was going for I I saw this out of
the corner of my eye I just couldn't
pick it up at the time okay we're having
a good time we're having a whole bunch
of fun to run err did okay oh good a
hallway and everything turned normal
colors
I see oh I see what you're doing
oh okay oh yeah
everything got quiet and I've got a long
narrow hallway and there's a spotlight
on a body it's all the spellings of
something bad reload here good thing I
don't lose bullets or else I'd be in a
lot of trouble
Brian the hardest difficulty you duel is
bullets all right what are you gonna do
yes it's pays to look oh yeah that run
written all over it oh god my store okay
thank you
whatever I don't care
hapless idiots go sacrifice themselves
for me that's fine she's right by me too
ladder ladder ladder
[Music]
I'm not disarming those I know she's
gonna be combined
thank you
burn you up laughter okay what was that
thing oh that's disgusting like a face
with a woman in six arms who's like the
thing from the forest well that was fun
glad I did
just in the nick knack of time I made it
I can't believe it either
dick I'd say because he's a detective oh
come on give me the poon gun and what a
poon zombies game is getting a little
stressful for me but uh just going down
off casual these stairs I'm sure
nothing's gonna chase me at any moment
now
nothing sorry I just need a breather oh
come on come on I didn't really need a
breather I was just saying that for a
fact
what do I do
okay okay there we go oh I just went
right through that thing what oh my god
are you kidding me that's awesome this
game went from combat horror kind of
annoy me to amazing oh that's the end of
it oh there's a bit of a full screen
problem there I see what's going on
there but either white wow that's
awesome
cuz so cool every bit of that and that
deuce back there with the tentacle face
I screw you okay so thank you all so
much for watching this is getting
awesome let me know what you think in
the comments below but this took a turn
for the amazing like I I was actually
kind of worried that it was gonna be too
combat-oriented but then it got really
creepy and cool and psychological and
there's already an enemy that I can't
kill and after a run away from that's
that I like that I like everything about
its gory its gritty its awful - I love
it so thank you all again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]
they wander around and die